every year millions of tourists take a
city break abroad and the same three
cities have topped the European rankings
since 2003 London is ahead of the rest
with 80 million overnight stays booked
by visitors the French capital Paris is
in second place
and Berlin remains in third place
euromaxx has visited famous sites as
well as offbeat attractions wave
accompany travelers to such places as
the catacombs in Rome or an abandoned
theme park in the German capital
for the last 10 years euromaxx has also
been right on trend with its trips to
the countryside whether getting away
from it all for a few days in a
traditionally constructed holiday
village in Austria or a few weeks
enjoying a family holiday on a houseboat
in the Netherlands euromaxx is always
where it's at glamping a glamorous take
on camping is a new luxurious way to get
back to nature like here in Spain I
think what people want is they want to
be out in nature and it'd be right yes
to have nature right on your doorstep
but still have the luxuries that you'd
have in a normal hotel room
we've also gotten sporty in all kinds of
ways going kayaking taking a dive
zooming down hill or defying gravity
health-conscious euromaxx has always
been a fan of pampering both body and
soul
travel operators have come up with
plenty of ways of doing just that over
the last 10 years
in 2010 for example euromaxx reported on
the traditional swiss hey bath treatment
and joined a spot ripped in Slovenia
designed especially for men as early as
2003 a lot of people were taking their
phones and laptops on holiday but since
then a new trend has developed
workaholics can now book an offline
holiday and voluntarily have their
smartphones confiscated as well as all
that we've embarked on gourmet trips
taking culinary city tours and going on
a lobster safari in Sweden where
tourists come face-to-face with the
local seafood in addition to knowing
what kind of holiday you're after it's
also important to know where you want to
go Germans have been favoring their home
country since 2003 after all it is
Europe's top holiday destination
but realized oh maybe it used to be
about being able to tell your neighbor
you went to such in such a place you
know it but now more people are
listening to their own needs and doing
what they want to do bavaria is
germany's most popular holiday region
though many visitors also head north to
the Baltic coast
some prefer the roughness of the North
Sea and take a trip for example to the
wadden sea national park Spain is
Europe's second favorite place to
vacation with its alluring combination
of sun sea and sand 384 million
overnights days were booked in Spain
last year followed by Italy which
registered 377 million overnight stays
that puts it in third place the capital
Rome is just one of many cities with
lots of exciting history and culture on
offer and there's a new trend more and
more tourists are heading to Eastern
European destinations last year the
numbers of guests in hotels went up by
eleven percent in this region and for
one more option if you've been
everywhere and done it all on earth you
can always kick back in orbit as a space
tourist